Free Speech ironically enough as
mind-blowing it is kind of meets
rightwing these days which is weird so
and I remember you showing me the
percentage of breakdown of people that
are leftwing rightwing right Chris and
you're like actually it's a lot more in
the middle that you would suspect how do
you avoid being labeled even from the
New York Times and the media positioning
Rumble oh those right- Wingers over
there it's like the reality is we're
just a free speech platform that should
be left right center up down how do you
avoid that uh that label it's it's a
great question and it's it's true the
the perception is totally different than
the reality um the the data just simply
the data not by Rumble but by com score
which is like the holy grail and the
advertising industry this is what people
spend their money behind so if the data
says this and it matches com score
advertisers put money behind it so the
data has Democrats as the number one
category on
Rumble stop and think about that right